listen up details readers do you think
you have an idea that could make a great
film have you ever gone to a movie
locked out of it and said how did that
crap get made here's an opportunity for
our readers to actually have a film mate
my name is IRA meistrich and i'm the
founder of next studios and we partnered
with details magazine to call your bluff
here's how it works we're going to take
one idea that's submitted from the next
and details community and we're going to
make it i'm dan paris on the
editor-in-chief of details and I
couldn't be more excited about this
partnership so if you think you got what
it takes submit please send your ideas
in treatment script idea in the back of
the napkin promise you they'll be
evaluated go through the directions on
the site the details and next executive
boards are going to look through it
everybody will get responded to one will
get selected maybe more than one will
get selected so please go to the website
and sign up now submit your ideas hope
to see at the box office